just as products today are you know big
data tells people who their users are
down to how they're watching it who this
person is their age demographics income
all that how much does someone know
their audience for their film like how
much do they really study and shrink it
down oh it's going to be a person in
this age range this income bracket
watching on our home television set it's
going to be at the holidays the truth to
that and it's great that you're bringing
that up is that's not a newbie writer or
a newbie producer and a hopeful director
that's in truth that's the component
they don't have to worry about as much
that is where it falls more into my role
or our role in the distribution world we
know those answers we know the audience
that we're selling to we're not directly
selling to an audience audience people
actually buying the movie at a you know
on iTunes we're selling to the company
in between that's placing that movie
there that's making it available to
audiences they tell us what we need and
then we kind of create content that's
going to deliver to that and through
that source a television channel is that
it's a platform that reaches audience
they know what their audience likes they
know all the metrics and details of that
audience they tell us what they need so
we know what's needed what we need from
a writer is to know can they write are
they reliable can they hit the genre
conventions well the reason I talk about
the goldmine your honor is in writing
for the green light and then also the
television chapter is it's a great way
of saying look you don't have to you
know you don't have to overthink it hit
these buckets focus on these types of
genres and even if you make mistakes
even if there's a novice errors like you
know slight inconsistencies or maybe a
typo it's going to be okay because
there's so few people who write that
kind of stuff the stuff that Hollywood
truly needs so you know metric hang out
whether the lead female is 42 or 47 is
meaningless in a way it's it's all right
middle-aged woman
that's all we need to know woman in
peril thriller got it are you hitting
the genre conventions great we're not
going to buy that script we're going to
hire your services as a writer to write
the script we do need we've already
figured out all that stuff and we'll let
you know about it that's how it really
works so for an individual writer for an
individual filmmaker don't sweat that
stuff that is the component of the
business that you truly can say all that
other people worry about that because
they're going to be informing me what I
need but first you got to get over that
hurdle of how you gonna have that
relationship and to get there focus on
the gold mine in genres build that
relationship get noticed then the steps
will follow it's a great point
you said that that they actually do need
to worry about because I think there's a
misconception that a lot of people oh
when I get to this level I won't have to
worry about that but then it's it's the
chicken before the egg type of thing
well at what point are you going to be
at that level so what are some things
that people really do need to pay
attention to to launch their career or
to get their work scene that they think
they don't to be mindful of where their
role fits in to the total landscape of
the business you know in distribution in
in the media business in general it's
really we're following the lead of an
audience
audiences tell us what they want and we
just have the skill sets the connections
and the ability to hear that find the
content that's going to work or find a
way to create it and then find the
people who can help us create it and
then package it and get it out to people
you know that's what distribution is and
for people who are trying to kind of
cross that first hurdle in their career
the thing they need to be very cognizant
of that and they need to be very
understanding that yes filmmaking is an
art but it is a business before it's an
art Thomas Edison did not invent the
film camera just because it was going to
open the pathways to creating great
stories
did it as a way to sell a product to
sell visual images that people would buy
Eadweard Muybridge who created series
photography there's a reason all the
characters and his work are nude because
they needed to sell the imagery they
needed to sell the package and in fact
the the famous horse that was running
and all four legs were up at the same
time it was a bet as to whether that
actually existed so I mean the first
movie which was Edward boy-boy bridges
running horse I don't know what it's
called it was a transacted produced this
for us so we can win a bet that's how
media works it's here is the audience
here's the money
produce something so it fits this and we
can continue that process going that
assembly line it's very easy to
criticize the assembly line when you're
on the creative site when you're new to
it you know I don't want to sell out I
don't want to just make frivolous junk I
get it but there is a great common
ground in the middle there where there's
an audience who want certain kinds of
content and our distribution company is
willing to pay for it helped put the
financing together and we need creative
people to jump in and make it happen
and there are amazing movies that are
very very shanwa oriented that that are
great stories meaningful and have
surpassed time in terms of you know
people still reference them and go back
to them and re-watch them and there are
very very very commercial products so
you know it's a business first films
would not get funded if there wasn't
money to pay for it and people wouldn't
be investing in movies if there wasn't a
profit to be made on the back end very
few very few I thought that was great
that she says I criticized the assembly
line because we do get a lot of comments
on my videos about that and not just the
the one that you did about your book but
you know people that it criticized the
comic book franchise and things like
that but the thing is is that it's there
for a reason and I'm not saying that I'm
a total fan of that genre
by any means and I get what they're
saying but I think it's a lot of times
hard for a lot of artists to accept that
because they are artists they don't want
to write just something that's going to
sell and it's finding that balance you
know we still need to get a job even
though we may not like doing certain
things we still need to bring in some
kind of income so it's an interesting
debate look the greatest works of art in
history go to Europe and go to some
museums the Renaissance its commissioned
work Michelangelo was a commissioned
artist you know the Sistine Chapel was
not a vision he had he was hired to
produce it he took his talent and his
initiative to bring life to it and to
make it a masterpiece but he was hired
to hey we got the ceiling and we don't
know what to do with it
so you know you came recommended to us
you know so it that's how it works and
that's that's been art from the
beginning
Great Expectations this giant book we
all had to read in high school reason
it's so giant is because Charles Dickens
had a whole family with dozens of kids
that he needed to feed and he was being
hired every two weeks to keep an
attentive audience entertained so he
said alright I'm going to keep this
story going because I'm making money
doing it and he was being paid by the
magazine because of the magazine had an
audience willing to pay for it to keep
it going
the money comes first if there's not
money there if there's not something to
be transacted upon a profit to be made
there is no art there's nothing to be
created because no one's going to pay
for it except a couple of wacky people
who are willing to sink money into some
projects but if you want a career and if
you want to get to a point where you can
express your artistry you first have to
know and prove more importantly prove
that you can actually get the job done
in the first place so is there a way to
soften the sellout label it's been
bandied around so much and I get why
people go there but I feel like
sometimes it's overused my opinion is it
but selling isn't selling out
selling out is sort of when you like you
just throw in the towel in a sense like
you you always say this working in a way
where you are creating stuff that
matches what audiences one is not
selling out
you can look there's still so much you
know latitude you can have with a script
with a story even if you're working in
the convention of woman in peril
thriller or aging male Action Hero
film you know like those that's just
that's an architecture you know like the
great art I've used this reference
before and some other interviews I've
done like like great architects have
rules they have to follow there's
gravity we have to deal with that fact
we have to deal with building codes we
have to deal with the costs of creating
the structure you know it's not an
open-ended budget the bridge has to
serve a function it can't just be
something artistically and architectural
II profound there has to be a purpose
for it and there has to be a reason why
its existing what makes it art is what
you do with that how much of yourself
you put into that so getting to a point
where you were presenting yourself to
the market and saying I can do this
stuff and I can add a spin to it that's
not selling out of selling yourself
that's building your career and that's
getting you to a point where you're
actually going to have clout you're
going to have connections you're going
to have a track record you're going to
have a whole history of films or
projects that you've been associated
with that have been successful
commercially viable and then you can
cash in on some of those great
connections you have and say I want to
do something a little bit different
that's why I always go back to the gold
mines on Rah's I say don't write drama
don't write comedy what I mean is don't
write them out of the gate you have a
great idea
keep it on the back burner for a bit
because once you build your career and
you have connections you can then take
it off and say look I know I'm known for
this kind of thing but we have a great
relationship and what do you think of
this
you now have opened that door to create
something fantastic and forget most of
the film directors that are so well
renowned today look at where they began
I mean look at how many careers Roger
Corman started you know it's most great
talent you know don't rush out of the
gate with masterpieces and robert towne
who wrote chinatown also wrote Days of
Thunder like this is just the way it is
it's a business and we all have to pay
bills and selling selling yourself and
being paid for your work and having a
successful work is nothing to be ashamed
of
frankly people that feel that way I want
to throw that label around probably
aren't going to get too far they're
shooting themselves in the foot right
why do you think people go there with
that label uneasy I think it's I think
it's really really easy I think it's
really easy to cut others down I think
it's really easy to call anybody who's
doing something that is slightly
commercial a sellout
you know label them because god forbid
they might actually become a little bit
successful doing it I think it's also an
easy way to cover up for one's own
insecurities about their own work I
think that happens a lot too he's a
sellout she's a sellout you know
whatever it's like well how are your
work going to get the 22-point be
frankly I don't know too many people in
boardroom meetings talents when they
come in to pitch their work who have a
really pissy attitude I don't really see
them get too far it's usually much more
of a collaborative conversation it's
usually much more about how can we work
together how can we do this what do you
need in the story being being receptive
of notes and feedback you know those are
people that do well in life and do very
well in this career the people that sit
there going no it's my way or the
highway and you don't have a track
record of anything behind you but who's
going to invest in your project frankly
it's just my opinion there's probably
there's always an outlier a one amazing
script
it's once in a blue moon but to be
honest I've never heard of it or seen it
I'll keep my eyes open though okay
you